a young man
is born with an amazing ability for
horse riding
uh just natural gift
and everyone in the village says oh
you're so lucky and the monk says we'll
see
and then he falls off his horse and
breaks his leg and his career is over
and everyone in the village says you're
so unlucky and the monk says
we'll see
and then war breaks out and all the men
are sent to battle but he can't go
because of his busted leg and everybody
in the village says you're so lucky and
the monk says we'll see like good news
bad news who knows what there are things
that happen in our lives and when you
think about your own personal life
things that have gone horribly wrong you
know my my journey and my career started
with absolute pain you know i was sort
of like in this depressed state you know
lost my passion
and it turned out to be the greatest
thing that ever happened to me now do i
want to go through it again absolutely
not
good news bad news
who knows you know some of the biggest
struggles we go through we learn our
greatest lessons